organizaciones sociales de trabajadores
campesinos e indígenas se declararon en
resistencia a nivel nacional en ecuador
rechazó el incremento de presión en
combustibles el congelamiento de precios
anunciado recientemente por el
presidente guillermo lasso se realizó
con nuevos precios aumentados a gasolina
súper e se elevó de 2 a 3 con 39 dólares
lo que significa un 69 por ciento de
aumento no suena extra pasó de 1 con 48
2 con 55 significando 72% de aumento
mientras que el diesel pasó de un dólar
a 1 con 90 significando un 90 por ciento
de incremento calificado por algunos
sectores como un supuesto congelamiento
engañoso según los dirigentes de
organizaciones sociales que él manda la
derogatoria los decretos que liberaliza
a los precios a combustibles que no
fueron eliminados y podría ser revisada
en cualquier momento por ejecutivo
nacional en materia ambiental rechazar
los decretos de expansión de las
fronteras mineras y petroleras que
afectarían mayormente los territorios
poblados con las nacionalidades
indígenas de ecuador en materia laboral
también salieron a rechazar la propuesta
económica del ejecutivo nacional las
movilizaciones fueron calificadas por el
gobierno como protestas rurales de baja
intensidad pero de igual forma los
dirigentes han asegurado que se
mantendrán de manera progresiva y que
irán hoy si se mantendrán de forma
indefinida